China's defense minister has addressed
Asia's top security conference the
Shangri-La dialogue strained ties
between Beijing and Washington have been
dominating discussions Lee Shang Fu said
the world is big enough for both the U.S
and China to grow together
China seeks to develop a new type of
major country relationship with the
United States as for the U.S side it
needs to act with sincerity match its
words with deeds and take concrete
actions together with China to stabilize
the relations and prevent a further
deterioration China and the U.S should
properly handle differences Brave
difficulties and find a way to get along
the past few years of seeing China U.S
relations at record lows since forming
diplomatic ties
Florence Louis has the latest now from
Singapore
General Lee Xiang Fu speech was very
much in line with what we expected to
hear essentially it's about China
positioning itself as the alternative
Global power to the US he talked about
how China wants peace and stability in
the world and he talked about China's
role as Peacekeeper and mediator there
were thinly disguised Digs at the U.S
accusing it of interfering in other
countries Internal Affairs of
intensifying an arms race he described
the US's freedom of navigation
operations in this area as a pretext for
Supremacy now on the issue of Taiwan he
said this is a core interest of China
and that reunification will happen now
he added that while China strives for
peace it cannot promise to renounce the
use of force now this is an area where
China has been increasingly assertive in
the last week the U.S has accused the
Chinese military of performing at least
two dangerous Maneuvers at Sea and in
the air near Taiwan General Lee's
response when asked about this was well
those foreign forces shouldn't come so
close to China
Florence Louis Al Jazeera Singapore
let's bring in Andrew Leong he's an
independent China consultant and analyst
and joins us live from Hong Kong via
Skype Andrew good to have you with us
the Chinese defense minister says the
world is big enough for the US and China
to grow together but Chinese officials
turned down a request at this conference
for direct talks with the Americans so
why the duplicity from China
but of course I have the um Beijing
Fields also it's important to maintain
channels of communication let's not
forget that as we speak
um the American assistant Secretary of
State uh for Asia is heading to Beijing
to meet um with his counterparts and of
course in Singapore the China's defense
minister also hold private talks with
Americans allies like Japan and South
Korea but then of course the high level
pops directly between the two defense
ministers China is resisting that as a
signal to American hypocrisy because in
Beijing is spelled that the America and
the United States is saying one thing
and doing another saying that it's not
trying to derail the progress of China
but on the other hand so it's
interesting it's interesting Andrew you
talk about hypocrisy because the U.S
defense secretary Austin said
Washington's extremely concerned about
aggressive Chinese fighter jets
operating against U.S aircraft over
international waters in the South China
Sea China says it wants a better
relationship with the U.S but its
military actions prove otherwise
pictures
well um it it needs to be put in a
broader context because even before the
dialogue even before the recent
um direct confrontation uh between the
United States and China
um China Sea Lane of communication which
is of course the not only the South
um the timeline straight but it's all
trying to see is surrounded and circled
by American Military assets uh the first
island chain Center in Okinawa the
second island chain Center in Guam
together with the um the military took
points in Singapore which controls the
throat as it were of the float of
China's lifeblood of trade of
importation of energy so if we were in
China and you're being being encircled
naturally you put a lot of defenses
um and of course the um the United
States has been conduct conducting
so-called freedom of navigation
um Petros
um okay provocatively challenging China
claimed the territorial claims so so
let's quickly let's quickly touch on
some of the geopolitics Andrew I mean
Lloyd Austin also said Russia's invasion
of Ukraine highlighted how dangerous the
world's become when big countries invade
their smaller peaceful neighbors with
impunity do you think that was an
oblique reference to China and possible
military action against Taiwan
well the the United States is is
paddling this rhetoric uh the Taiwan
could be repeat of Ukraine
um without realizing of course the
Beijing has published there are three
white papers consecutively on Taiwan the
last
um release immediately after the Nancy
pelusi visit recently uh all confirming
China's preference for peaceful
unification
um but of course without renouncing the
use of force um forever because the
United States is trying to hollow out
they want to China policy trying to
create more and more space but I want to
perform as if Paramount was a separate
country and I'm in Taiwan turning power
one to a military porcupine okay
um so I think that the um but on the
other hand the preference is still on
Peaceful unification just like Hong Kong
um Andrew Lang we have to leave it there
thank you very much indeed sir for your
time thank you
thank you very much